[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
integrating spatial resolution into flow
cytometric analysis
i am michelle ashton of flabroots and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinths and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
heaven roberts protein and cell analysis
group at thermo fisher scientific
heaven you may now begin your
presentation
hi thank you michelle for the
introduction
as michelle mentioned i'm kevin roberts
and i'm very proud today to be
presenting um about the in-vitrogen
attuned psychics flow cytometer
and how you can integrate that spatial
resolution or imaging into your
traditional flow cytometry analysis
so as i mentioned i'm focusing today on
the sight picks and um we can come back
to this slide if there are questions but
just want to emphasize this is still in
a tune
and so the attuned cytometer line uses
acoustic focusing and you'll see that
we're capturing really very well focused
images of a wide variety of cell types
and across a wide range of run rates
and that is because of this acoustic
focusing
as i mentioned we image many cells and
sometimes we have a lot of fun with what
we run through our sitepix instruments
so essentially anything you can put
through a cytometer you can image on the
site picks so here we have some yeast
we have some sort of a spent necrotic
immune cell with platelet aggregates
we have two species of algae or diatoms
and then we have a piece of debris that
sometimes you'll see debris and you just
start seeing things when you've been
looking at images for far too long
i want to break today's presentation
into kind of four segments so
really i'm talking about problematic
samples and rare events and how the site
pics can help with those samples
also the unfortunate story of
contaminant identification and how
valuable the instruments become in our
own r d labs for this
for unknown samples or samples where you
are unsure of the phenotype whether
you're measuring autofluorescence or
you're measuring staining in disease
um this can really help you with gait
definitions and with doing titrations
and sample preparation
and this kind of leads into developing
brand new flow protocols
maybe even of samples you've never
worked with before or samples you've
worked with a lot and are just now
discovering some new features
so first let's talk about some
problematic samples and rare events
these can be difficult to work with and
i know we've all had that question what
is this dot
the first thing we get asked of the site
picks by new users is can you see
doublets and yes you certainly can so
here we have several aggregates and i've
used our image back gating feature where
i just click on the image and i back it
onto any plot in my workspace
and i've put four potential aggregate
exclusion plots
so the back gated aggregates that are
doublets or triplets are in these orange
dots and then you can see the gray areas
the majority of my events
i only backated about 50 events just to
kind of show this as an example
but you can see here of the four
candidate plots
really only side scatter area versus
height is doing a great job at
giving me a range that i can work in to
draw a really good singlet gate but even
inside scatter area in height you can
see there's at least one orange dot down
there right in the middle of my where i
would draw singlets
so
if you are noticing that you're coming
up with a lot of brand new conclusions
on double phenotype cells
i highly encourage you to reconsider
your duplicating
first i would i have found that using a
very very tight side scatter area versus
height
singlet gate is usually the best way to
go
i've done this example on now hundreds
of samples
and very consistently this is
the best gate for an aggregate exclusion
but also make sure that it's very tight
up against that density
in addition even though an event is well
within those bounds that doesn't mean
it's not a doublet so just always keep
that in mind when you're doing your
downstream gating
this is some data that a colleague of
mine put together
he was looking at one of our new live
dead viability dies here it's the live
dead fixable lime
and i think we've all seen somewhat of
an intermediate population when we're
looking at live dead plots
so sometimes that intermediate
population is as it is here i'm kind of
shouldering off of that bright positive
population
and we're pretty confident we want to
choose just this left most negative peak
other times the intermediate population
is shouldered against the negative
population
so really titrating your viability dyes
can be very important
because there's been kind of contention
for a while at least from my
understanding on whether or not this
intermediate population are dead cells
or are these live cells that are
starting to go into the steps of
necrosis
so we can see here that that leftmost
gate are there are live healthy cells
those are the ones we're after
the rightmost gate of course those are
our dead cells but the intermediate gate
is also dead in fact they're so far dead
that they've started to lose their
membrane integrity
so for viability dyes that are staining
nucleic acids if the dna is breaking
down or if they're staining proteins and
the cells leaking protein
this can really interfere with your
staining separation
for those viability dies so it's really
nice to have the site picks to be able
to do this quick gait check
and make sure that i'm only including
the live healthy cells i'm interested in
here's a problem sample we might call it
where we don't want to exclude dead
cells and we don't want to exclude
doublets but we still want to get rid of
debris
and we still want to learn more about
the sample itself
so this is a car t cell killing assay
where our target cells our ramos cells
are stained with the cell trace violet
dye
and our car t cells are stained with
cell trace far red
so we can see of this beautiful quadrant
plot and we're able to determine which
cell population is where
um but the actual placement of those
gates can vary quite a bit from sample
to sample and depending on your
incubation times
and the efficacy of the t cells that
you've
introduced the car
so it's important to be able to look at
those images and see where the actual
population cutoff is what is debris
but also we can learn a lot about the
timing and the methods behind
how we measure these outcomes so here
we've just incubated for one hour
after an hour what we were seeing is
that the majority of the events in that
q2 quadrant
are truly interacting
so we're having a true immune synapse
these aren't just two cells that are
coming through the instrument together
you can see that here the car t is
actually attaching to the realm of cell
and initiate initiating killing
moving on a bit to kind of a more
problematic sample in a true sense
so this is an aged blood sample and i'm
sure we've all been in the position
where unfortunately due to a centrifuge
being down or
a sample being delayed in shipment
we get our sample we can't send it back
we certainly can't ask for a replicate
sample the day is gone
so let's make the best of what we have
and let's see what we can get out of
this sample that still generates some
good quality data
so here we've taken some blood that's
about 36 hours old
we have done a centrifuge uh density
gradient centrifugation to separate out
our pbmcs
but we can see in this
leftmost of these three large plots that
we have a large contaminant population
we've got that r1
so we would assume that these are mostly
residual granulocytes
probably mostly neutrophils maybe some
necrotic cells
in addition in the next plot we see this
r3 population so these would be low cd45
or intermediate cd45 expressing
hopefully lymphocytes
i've always been trained that these
cells should be gated out but their
actual placement can be a little tricky
so here they're pretty clearly separated
from my main lymphocyte population
but that's in part because i've titrated
this antibody specifically for this
application
that's not always the case
so sometimes they're a bit more
shouldered up to that main population
and they can be a little harder to pull
out
but some researchers have told me that
they don't gate these out they feel that
they are a valid population to include
in a downstream analysis
and that this kind of intermediate cd45
expression is of biological consequence
and not an error and not because of
necrosis
we also always have this lovely
intermediate cd14 monocyte population
some of these may be non-classical
monocytes they're an interesting
population to look at but we won't look
at those today
i want to look at r1 and r3
so in r1 this high side scatter
population you can see we do have indeed
some granulocytes
and certainly a lot of cells that are
going through necrosis and apoptosis
some of them are very dead
and others are even still residual
doublets even without or even with a
very tight singlet gate
for that r3 population these are not
cells that i would want to include in my
downstream gating
so these cells are going through
necrosis apoptosis
you can see that some of them are
shrinking
and you know further advanced in that
apoptotic pathway
others have these apobodies
floating with them or attached to them
it's a bit unclear to us if these
apoptotic bodies are from this cell and
they're being detached
while it's going through the instrument
or are these floating in suspension
because aged blood is going to put off a
lot of april bodies
but it's still interesting to see these
cells and kind of confirm that i don't
want them in my downstream
lymphocyte gates
this is kind of the full gating strategy
for the same sample
and here i'm looking at nk like t cells
so you can see i've removed my cd14s
i'm only looking at cd45 positive events
in the lymphocyte gate
this sample had numerous other gates
associated with it but this is the
pathway we'll look at for now
and
on its own i would be very happy with
this i felt the titrations were
appropriate
and you can see i've got a good
separation of a small population but
that's to be expected
so what i can do now is look at the
images of all the cells in that
population
and at 0.17 percent of total events you
know i always have suspicions about rare
event work and now i can actually see
whether or not these are real cells are
they electronic noise are they just dead
cells that are picking up stain that
really doesn't belong to them
so they certainly are not electronic
noise and i will say that after looking
at millions of images i can tell you
these look like nk like t cells this is
the expected morphology
but you can see that a couple of them
have one has a spent platelet
we have an example here of one that has
these two small april bodies again this
might have been picked up from another
cell
so we could improve this gait
we aren't sure what that platelet or
apobodies are carrying with them in
terms of phenotype
and it would be concerning if we were
trying to make a new discovery based on
this gate knowing that we have some
contaminants
so here i've just redrawn that gate and
i've called it repeat gate so this is
the same gate as the previous slide and
then i've redrawn it
after removing every single problematic
event the problematic events here are
just back gated in pink
and you can see that i've dramatically
dropped down my
percent of gated events but now repeat
gate 2 is a pure gate this only contains
nk like t cells to the very best of my
ability
so i think that the power of this is
that it really gives you some evidence
and if you're submitting for publication
maybe you're submitting your gates
especially for those rare events with
these images to show
here are the images that we identified
that are non-target events they
represent a small percentage of our
original gate or even saying we've
refined that gate based on these images
and now we have something like this
repeat gate to
a pure gate
so now we're going to move on to kind of
a sad story of contaminant
identification
i think that many of us have experienced
this probably even more than realize but
contaminants do i do happen even in
really well controlled cell cultures
rooms
so this was again this was actually the
same assay on a different day um a car t
cell ramos killing assay
and we noticed a researcher noticed on
um on a different instrument that they
had kind of this altered forward inside
scatter profile than what they were
expecting
so we ran the samples on sight picks
instrument and we saw that even though
these events were all staining positive
for our ramos
stain again this happened to be cell
trace violet
they certainly don't all look like ramos
cells
so in roi3 kind of that low side scatter
that's where we would really expect our
romo cells to be and you can see they're
there but they seem to have some friends
in roi1 with this high side scatter
these do not look like ramos cells at
all in fact this is what we suspect to
be a fungal pathogen
coincidentally we had run the same cell
line about a week earlier on the sitefix
instrument so we were able to go back
and look at that experiment
and we did see just a tiny fraction of
events that looked like those roi 3
images it looks like a fairly healthy
ramos cell but it had these coincidence
events
at the time we didn't notice or we kind
of passed off as debris
but of course now we're on the alert
so we bleach everything
we toss the cultures and and we think
all as well
and unfortunately several months later
we see the same contaminant and this
time in gercat cells so a different cell
line these two cell lines are never
interacting with each other but they do
share the same media
so we spoke with our cell culturist and
she mentioned yeah our ramos cells we
thought last week didn't survive
cryopreservation
this isn't entirely abnormal so we just
thought well maybe the thaw wasn't good
and had tossed that particular vial of
cells and she'd started thawing another
we can see here the jerk out cells are
doing much better with this contaminant
than the ramos were
but we still have some of those really
clustered pathogen events
so we decided to look at that new thaw
for almost cells and these are just two
days post thaw and you can see some very
early signs of very heavy contamination
it was interesting that these have a
slightly altered morphology they're a
bit shorter than the more mature
pathogen
but after we incubate them a bit longer
they do lengthen out and is the same
species
i also like these images because the
large cell the ramos cell is actually
triggering
my side scatter
but because the
small events are coming through the core
at the same time you can see how the
core the acoustic focusing is really
aligning all of these events
you can see it here in a two-dimensional
space but this is actually
three-dimensional and this is why we're
able to get pretty well-focused images
of something as large as a ramos cell
next to something as small as about a
micron in diameter
because of that three-dimensional
stability
and this is just another image these
were those rama cells a few days later
you can see these are very unhealthy
unhappy cells
but because the site pics was able to
pick up on these pathogens now that we
know what we're looking for
several days before something like
trypan blue or just not seeing
confluence
we're now able to put our cell cultures
we can run them off of plates using the
site kick
or we can even just quickly run them out
of tubes and we can kind of screen when
we have new lines coming on or lines
that we haven't worked with before
to make sure that we're keeping our cell
culture incubators nice and clean
so now i want to move on to some more
for me exciting some unknown samples and
new ways to do gate definition
using the sightfix instrument
so here i have what we'll call a mixed
culture sample or an environmental
sample and while i'm working with
autofluorescence you could use this same
approach and i have used this approach
after staining cells where i don't know
which cells are going to take up which
stain
but i do know that i'm hoping that my
staining
will separate my populations a bit
so here i'll add uh n by n plots to my
workspace so if i have three stains i'll
have you know three by three uh here i'm
using autofluorescence so i actually put
all of them up but i've just shown a
couple as an example
i also of course looked at ford inside
scatter but you can see i just kind of
have this continuous smear almost
that's really not very helpful in ford
and side scatter even if i change them
to height or to log form
but it looks like red one
maybe blue one are going to be really
valuable so i've decided to keep these
in this example
and what i'm going to do here is instead
of drawing a gate around these
populations or what i think are
populations and then looking at those
images
is you can look at the images and you
can just find cells that look similar
and you can back eight those cells onto
your your workspace and it will back it
onto all these plots at once
and so now i'm going to look at the
fluorescence of each population instead
of going the other way around
here's just one example population i
know these are small and maybe look a
little uninteresting but to some they're
probably very valuable
but you can see they're very small
foreign side scatter
and pretty low in their fluorescence as
well
when we compare that to these
which are very
dispersed in their forward side scatter
and somewhat dispersed in red
they are however higher in
autofluorescence than the previous cells
so using this i came up with a gating
strategy i can honestly say i would have
never considered before
here i have three areas of interest i've
called them oi1 2 and 3. they're on the
top left
i actually decided to combine them so
these are things that i said these are
cells and these are cells that i care
about in my downstream research
to remove some
very egregious aggregates i've drawn
what i've called a singlet enriched gate
i didn't remove all aggregates this way
but it's close
off of red to
area and width
and then
out of that i've
identified four
major populations or important
populations
they're certainly not major in their
count you can see that population 4 is
only 0.39 of my gated events
you'll see in a moment why this
population is important
population 3 i couldn't fully separate i
keep saying i'll come back to this and
maybe someday i will but i would like to
stay in these samples and run them again
and try some different staining and
separation protocols to better separate
population three
this is just those populations back
gated onto a couple of those original
plots
and you can see that they're not exactly
where i thought they would be
so the continuous population in blue one
and red one where i would have called
that
high population in both parameters a
single population is very much two
distinct populations
again forward inside scatter is not very
valuable
in this situation i should say
and i said that i had identified four i
actually stopped at 11 and from those 11
you know again the singlet and the
aggregate enriched
you can do this fairly quickly and i
usually back eat
anywhere from 10 to 30 events
however many you feel you need to get a
good consistent population sometimes you
have them all land at the same spot you
only need five or ten
but you can really do a lot with this
image back gating tool and really
investigating where those events fall
across these different fluorescent
parameters and i use this a lot whether
i'm working with
algae fungi or immune cells
here are those four populations and you
can see population four i mentioned
earlier it's very minor in its
percentage
but this appears to be a dead population
so these are dead or dying i believe
chlorella vigorous
all of these species are
known for different sensitivities to
toxins and to culture
conditions
so if i'm applying culture conditions or
in my case a toxin
to this culture i really want to watch
this population because this may indeed
be the population i care the most about
and in this otherwise robust healthy
sample it's very minor but if that
population grows i want to know about it
and as quickly as i can
population three is actually two species
and one species has two forms so you can
see this on the left you'll see 3a is
the small form of the chlorophyngenesis
and on the right is this larger darker
form it's much more autofluorescent
every scientist always wants to talk
about what they're doing next so i'm
excited now to talk about some new flow
protocols i'm working on and also what
our software team is working on as well
so this is a sample that i never worked
with before and would have really not
felt comfortable working with before
using the sitefix instrument uh and just
starting to dive into this
so
here i i have a sample and you'll see it
here in a moment what that sample is but
i had an original idea of how i wanted
to get my debris and i was just going to
say that all of my really high side
scatter and all of my really low side
scatter was debris
this sample i have stained with cell
trace violet i'm trying to track
these particular cells
um so i was pretty comfortable that what
i thought were my cells of interest are
all staining intermediate to high with
my cell trace violet die
but if i just look at that population
after looking at the images i can see
there's still some debris
and so instead i kind of went back to
the drawing board and i started looking
at those end by end plots just as i
showed in the previous example
and what i found was that i could do a
lot better job of removing debris if i
used of all things yellow one
so by choosing just an intermediate
population in my yellow one channel
these cells in particular
separated out quite nicely there
if i look at that high population which
i've called r1 you can see that that has
a very dispersed side scatter profile
and so really no side scattergate that i
could have drawn would have removed
all of this debris
in fact i'm only capturing about 75 of
my debris if i use my original side
scatter gate
so definitely use your autofluorescence
to your advantage it's not your enemy
it can be tricky to work with but it can
also be very valuable
these are the cells i was working with
and these are powdery mildew a pathogen
of hops
you can see that
and my intermediate yellow and
intermediate to high cell trace violet i
have these beautiful complete events the
reason they're intermediate to high is
that there's actually several cells
within this casing
however in that high yellow one i have
these large aggregates of debris
there's still cells
they're still events but i do want to
remove them
and so as i'm working through my process
to do gradient separation or improving
my isolation protocol this is the
population i'm trying to get rid of and
r2 is the population i'm trying to keep
once we start taking the next step and
saying well instead of back getting my
images can i get data from those images
and
this is what our software team has been
working on
so we're looking at
image processing that's brought back
into the itunes software so instead of
looking at this in something like image
j i'm able to look at this in line with
all of my fluorescent parameters
and so this is just an example you can
see on the left where i've taken
something we're going to call entropy
intensity
so
um
and i've put that against a live dead
dye
and you can see that if i only had the
live dead dye these populations would
not separate very well i don't have very
bright staining of my dead
dead cells
but once i include that entropy
intensity of the events i can separate
these populations uh quite well
this sample is differentiated to hl60
cells and hl60s do differentiate on
their own
at a low percentage
but of course differentiated cells are
going to have a little bit lower
skewness intensity or
if you think of skewness intensity in
terms of roughness of the surface
so those undifferentiated cells are a
little bit more erratic
they're ready to turn into anything we
want but our differentiated cells which
happen to be differentiating into
neutrophils they begin become smoother
and they become much rounder
than the original hl60s
so it's exciting when i started to dig
into this and see that you know this
might actually be an earlier indicator
of differentiation
that i could then use to help me time my
downstream work which is neutrophil
migration and phagocytosis assays
this also makes singlet counting even
simpler so earlier i showed you that
maybe side scatter area versus height
for the
honestly the vast majority of
um mammalian cells is is really the way
to go
um there's you know coming soon is an
even simpler way to do that and that's
something
called spot count or particle count
and now i can just draw a very simple
histogram gate and you can see that
these blue outlines are where it's
saying there's a cell
as opposed to when i have aggregates
i have multiple cells or in this case
cells with beads
some of these other features are also
very helpful in separating
different types of cells or again cells
and beads
here i just have one population i've
tagged is residual beads
these are human pbmcs that i stimulated
with beads and they were destined for a
downstream debeating assay
so as i'm working through that beating
assay i want to see this residual bead
population disappear
and i want to see my healthy detached
cell population remain intact
the unhealthy cells that are kind of
that intermediate population i'm not too
worried about those if i lose them in my
debeating assay
they were already going through
apoptosis or necrosis and again i can
see that
using some of these extracted parameters
as well as of course viability in an xn5
staining
here's another example of how this can
really clean up a sample
so this is a mouse whole lung homogenic
prepared by a colleague of mine
and for those that have done mouse lung
homogeneity it's not an easy matrix to
work with she's trying to preserve as
many cells as possible
and so really trying to minimize sample
preparation uh to the utmost degree
so has a very simple staining process
and this is for essentially starting the
process of titrating your antibodies
and so first thing we want to know is
are we titrating on live nuclei
nucleated cells
and here yes we are i mean these are
staining negative for a live dead dye
they are stating positive for a nucleic
acid dye
you know she's prepared the proper fmos
etc
and that does clean up this data
substantially
but when we look at the images we can
see that
while there are cells in these images
many of them are still attached to
debris
some of them have large blebs and other
evidence of apoptosis and we certainly
don't want to go through the whole
process of
sorry in xn5 folks but an xn5 staining
adds another level of complexity to
sample prep that can be a bit
problematic when you're trying to do a
lot of titrations on a very small number
of cells
so another option is to use some of our
extracted features to really clean up
these cells so here we're only looking
at cells that have a fairly high
intensity
erythrocytes because the images are
illuminated off of a violet laser will
show up almost black from the heme and
so we can remove any residual red blood
cells
that survive the lysis by having a
little bit higher normalized intensity
as a threshold
additionally circularity or the the
smoothness of the edges of that cell
will really reduce the amount of blebs
and apoptotic cells that you include in
your sample
but not only does this dramatically
clean up the fluorescent plots with the
nucleic acid and live dead staining but
you can see this really cleans up uh her
scatter plots and
just really makes this imageview gallery
look much more beautiful
these are the cells that we're after and
these are the cells that we want to
titrate on if we're titrating on cells
that are dead or dying
or have bits of aggregate we're always
going to find
frustrations in those titrations and
ultimately we'll waste reagents and
definitely waste time
this is just an example of kind of using
the same approach and
using it with the sitekick autosampler
so because we can extract this data even
off of sight kick experiments this was
very exciting to start using this as a
screening assay on 96 well plates
so these happen to be um these are
saccharomyces cervaceae that i treated
with carbendazine which is a fungicide
and i treated them with varying levels
of uh carbenezine or i'll call it cbc
for 18 hours uh and
what i noticed is that when i did this
uh
extraction is i got a much cleaner
separation of my treatments using a
combination
of these extracted parameters along with
traditional flow parameters
so here i've used side scatter and again
the entropy intensity
and you can see that my disease sample
which i'll call it here on the left
these are very shrunken i presume nearly
dead
unfortunately because these picked up
every stain i threw at them they made
the staining profileness nearly
impossible
and so it was much easier and and
frankly much more robust
to use these extracted parameters in
combination with my flow parameters
because of the altered staining profile
of these deceased events
here's my full titration curve
you can see that that disease state
gate just disappears
quite rapidly and is almost non-existent
it's 0.6 percent
once we get down into the control or the
zero micromolar
these are just this is a heat map of our
replications so these are six biological
replications so each was
pipetted separately for the carbendazine
and you can see it's extremely
consistent
using this gating strategy
i don't know that i've ever seen one of
my titration curves at least go this
well
so i was very happy to see how
consistent these were
uh and how robust that gating strategy
was and it really helped me to determine
that really that effective dose for
inducing this in saccharomyces was
somewhere between four and 800
micromolar
i might want to dial that in and and
repeat
but also hopefully
kind of investigate further what's
causing this and this is not the normal
mechanism of action for crepenessing to
my knowledge
this is another example of how in
addition to offering a very
straightforward and robust gating
strategy
we can really show where our typical
gaining strategies have kind of fallen
apart so even for in a very experienced
user and using the image back eating we
certainly still make mistakes
and this is just one more tool to reduce
those mistakes
so here i've looked at where i would
have drawn a singlet gate as opposed to
my singlet counting
with these extracted features
and what i found is that i'm i'm missing
quite a few of my singlets they would
fall outside of my singlet gate
they're going to be much lower in their
side scatter height versus area ratio
and so if i'm doing my best to exclude
doublets i'm removing singlets
conversely i'm including about 27
percent of my doublets in a singlet gate
so these are doublets that even with a
fairly tight singlet gate i i just
couldn't remove in traditional ways
so this is certainly very valuable for
making sure that especially if you have
that rare event analysis where a doublet
can make all the difference in the world
having this really robust singlet
doublet discrimination is super valuable
this is an essay i'm sure many of you
used an xn5 and propitium iodine
and
having an intermediate population here
is not uncommon uh this can depend
greatly on how long you've incubated
your cells with your toxin etc
these are jerk cat cells with camp to
theisin
and i use the dead cell apoptosis kit so
you can see my nexon 5 staining on this
left plot
is on my y-axis
this intermediate population here is
about 15
of my singlets
and what was interesting in this is that
i
had the same user um gating on two
separate days
and you can see that where i have option
one and option two
i tend to draw these gates very
similarly i make little coffins
for my dead cells
and my apoptotic cells
and so at first glance they look very
similar
but even a very minor difference can
pretty heavily influence your downstream
uh outcomes
so if i'm trying to remove debris
through manual gaining
sometimes i can be inadvertently
introducing error and i think we've all
seen this and it's a known issue with
flow cytometry is that we have to be
very robust and careful with our gating
especially when we go from sample to
sample and day to day where we will have
mild variations because of biology or
instrumentation or staining
so if we look at this
compared to oops i apologize
um here instead of using that kind of
manual process of a side scatter and
forward scatter gate i've i've chosen to
use something that we're calling
pseudo-diameter so this is a derived
dirameter from the area
and
so for me this is a bit more applicable
to the cells as well i would expect
apoptotic bodies to be very small in
appearance and i would expect healthy
cells to be quite large these are jerk
hats
um keep in mind the pseudo-diameter at
this time is in in
pixels so essentially my threshold here
is for a 10 micrometer
cell
now if i look at just my large events
you can see that i have quite a few that
are
an x and five positive this is not
surprising given how much camtasia i
gave them
and
there we go
uh when i look at this in terms of
replication
um this was three sets of experiments so
the same cells the same toxin but
prepared in three slightly different
ways
and what i would hope to see is that one
gating strategy emerges
as the most robust gating strategy to
use even with these slight variations
and we can see that
in terms of percent cv
my diameter has the lowest average cv
across the three preparations and across
my replicas
a cv is is something that we can take
and apply across multiple experiments is
in terms of a success rate of our
gaining strategies that's why i chose to
use this to compare these
but i think to me this also plays back
to
you know i can very easily explain to a
new flow cytometrist or even a very
experienced flow cytometrist why i chose
a diameter
threshold and that diameter threshold
can be adjusted for each cell type but
is consistent from day to day
conversely a staining
threshold might be changed day to day
depending on your titrations and your
preparation
and of course your instrumentation
and so by integrating these derived
parameters that really have a lot of
biological
impact we can really start to improve
the consistency of our gates and
hopefully improve the consistency of our
final research outcomes
with that i do just want to thank
everyone for their time for the entire
team that has helped make this
instrument
what it is and also to allow me to speak
today
with that i will take any questions
thank you heaven for your informative
presentation
we'll now start the q a portion of the
webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask
question box located on the far left of
your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
okay let's go ahead and get started so
our first question is
when using site picks do you change your
flow rates to allow for better images
yeah thank you that's a good question
we can image at every flow rate and i do
not change my flow rates for images
um we actually we have some data on our
website showing the same cells imaged at
each flow rate
i personally get a little nervous even
just running at those high rates
but i think that's personal preference i
work with a lot of different cytometers
and so once you're past you know 200
microliters a minute i feel like you're
screaming fast
uh
but i adjust the instrument for my
staining for my cells for all the other
reasons we adjust flow rate first
and we always worry about the images
last we can take great images at each
flow rate so we definitely don't want to
um adjusting based on the images the the
images come last after those adjustments
already
made okay thank you
your next question how long does it take
to train new new users how to use the
site picks when compared to other
cytometers or even the attune nxt
yeah so the site fix is in a tune so
it's kind of the next generation of a
tune
and for users of the nxt i i really
think they're going to find it just
really walk up simple to learn
um the software is the same we've we've
added a couple of tabs of course for the
image adjustment
um but all the other features are are
identical between the nxt software and
the sitepix software they're actually
one platform
for a brand new user i when i first
started using the itunes i even i was
surprised at how easy it was to kind of
start learning the software
um
so the same can be said for the psychic
software we're able to train new users
fairly quickly we definitely spend much
more time discussing you know
fundamentals of flow and and and why you
might want to put a gate a certain way
or make a voltage adjustment a certain
way
the image adjustments themselves are
very quick
and i want to say that if all you were
worried about was image adjustment you
could probably train someone in under an
hour easily and that's a pretty long
training session um i've shown i've
shown lab mates in in a few minutes and
just said yeah here's your here's your
image tab and here's how you'll adjust
the focus and elimination and here's how
you know you've gone too far here's how
you know you're really close
so it's really straightforward and and i
think the software itself is is pretty
intuitive you know the our team does a
great job of of making sure that it's
very user friendly and
that you can kind of find what you're
after and you can move the pains around
as you need so
um compared to other cytometers
uh
some cytometers are great easy walk-up
user-friendly and others of course take
you know much more time to learn
so i would say that the site pics is is
somewhere on that lower end in terms of
the learning curve but definitely
feature rich
okay great thank you looks like we have
time for one more question
um why are some of the images a lighter
background and others have a darker
background so for example on the slide
with the dyna beads the bead images have
a light background
yeah so
at present the software is actually
scaling those images so
the images themselves are the same color
um but it's scaling them to
think of it like scaling it to the
darkest event so because the dyna beads
are so dark because they absorb violet
light
they're going to appear even darker on a
lighter background
you can certainly adjust the intensity
of the images in the software
you're not adjusting the image itself
just the display
and
of course you can take those images
offline as well and do further
adjustments to
the brightness and contrast if you wish
if you feel like you acquired them and
they're a little dark uh for your liking
you can
brighten them up we have found that
sometimes when we're printing posters
it's good to
uh make the images a little bit lighter
because depending on the poster ink uh
they can end up being a little darker
than you expected
but all of that is tunable in the
software and the images themselves have
the same illumination across the entire
sample
all right well thank you again heaven
for your time today and your wonderful
presentation
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor thermo fisher scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time
you